five o'clock Thursday morning we start
with breaking news a metro police
officer is in the hospital right now
there has been a shooting near UNLV in
fact there
are current crime scenes here and Nate's
going to talk about that in a moment how
that might impact you but first let's go
live out to Candace Charles uh you're at
the first scene Flamingo near University
Center Candace what can you tell us so
far
well right now as you can see caution
tape is up here on Flamingo all the way
from Palos Verdes down to Cambridge as
we mentioned Metro Police say one of
their officers is hurt following an
officer-involved shooting now police say
the officer was taken to a local
hospital it happened on Flamingo near
University Center we don't know many
details on what led up to this incident
of course we're working to find that out
now but as you can imagine police are
asking to take caution in the area and
use detours if you need to now police
are expected to be giving out more
details this morning as we learn more
we'll be sure to give you more so stick
with us right here on air online and on
social for the latest for now live from
Flamingo on Palos Verdes I'm Candace
Charles 8 News Now